well look we first of all we want to
make sure that there's every opportunity
to try to get these strikes settled so
we're opening the door we're opening our
books as well so that the information we
send to the independent pay review
bodies to make the recommendations on
pay is actually transparent and the
unions can see it and we hope that
they'll reciprocate in the meantime we'd
really like for them to cool off the the
strikes but also today we're saying look
there has to be a minimum safety level
that people can expect even on strike
days particularly in areas like
healthcare making sure that an ambulance
can turn up for example that's very
Patchwork at the moment other modern
European economies all have minimum
safety levels and we've announced that
we'll be introducing those in
legislation in law today as well a
number of trade unions have said that
this
will affect their members human rights
what do you say to that look I don't
think that's that's right first of all
civilized European nations France
Germany Italy Spain they all have some
form of minimum safety levels and the
international labor organization a U.N
body that the unions themselves sign up
to all say that there's nothing wrong
with having minimum safety levels
involved when it's a question of life
and death and if for example you've got
somebody who has a heart attack maybe a
stroke the idea that there may not be an
ambulance coming because there's a
strike on I think is unacceptable we're
not proposing to go the full hog other
countries parts of America Canada or
Australia they have legislation which
bans those blue lights and entirely from
going on on strike we're not proposing
that I think it's very reasonable what
we're suggesting but I think the time
has come and it brings us into line with
other European nations isn't this just
actually rather a lot of political
theater this is not going to be on the
books in time to affect this wave of
industrial action it could very well get
blocked by the House of Lords it could
very well be subject to Legal challenge
isn't this just political window
dressing well in point of fact I'd
rather we never have to go down this
this route in the most recent strikes
for example with ambulances you had the
Royal College of Nursing who in the
nurses strike did agree at a national
level what the minimum safety level
would be but with the ambulances that
was left to a postcode Lottery
effectively and I think it's that that's
unacceptable so what I'm hoping is that
across the economy because this would
apply in lots of different areas of the
economy I'm hoping actually that unions
and the employers can get together and
do sensible things in order to guarantee
a minimum safety or service level in
each different area that would always be
the preference what we're going to do is
take the powers to impose that if
required I'm going to be cheeky my
fourth question is going to be two
questions in one when do you think you
can actually get this into law and the
Prime Minister yesterday made a very
strong hint that there will be a
significant pay rise for public sector
workers this year what can you say about
that well first of all in terms of
timing we will introduce this quickly
into Parliament it will be during what's
known as this session in other words
this year in Parliament quite how
quickly that travels through will be a
matter for Parliament itself but
conservatives have a strong majority I
don't think it would be right to block
this we had it in our Manifesto that we
would bring in some minimum safety and
service levels so I see this going um
through and look in terms of future pay
settlements we want the hard-working
people in our public sectors to be well
paid in fact you know nurses for example
received a pay rise last year even when
because of kovid all other areas of
Public Service didn't get a pay uh
increase the prime minister's rightly
said that independent pay review bodies
is the place to settle this the
government accepts that but what we're
going to do is actually be completely
open with our information and publish
the data invite the unions to do the
same I hope have a much more Cooperative
Spirit as we go into the pay settlements
for this year 23
24. so it would be up to the independent
pay review bodies of course where that
lands